i'm just trying to think is there
anything in like uk or australia that is
like unnecessarily like slow i feel like
we just kind of get rid of it
yeah i mean we've already complained
about that i feel like as in like the
systems that we have i don't really
think there's anything that's like
everything's been
like easy to do i mean i've i didn't
really have experience
living on my own right in australia so i
can't really say that
everything that could be done online is
done online you know yeah i
i mean yeah i cannot even i don't even
think i ever went anywhere in person for
anything like a government like you
could all be done by phone or
online yeah water bill internet
phone government documents like local
tax
like all of it was done online i think
the only thing really is like you know
going to get like your driver's license
fixed or something right like you
probably have to go in person
then in the uk you can you can uh get a
meltdown yeah i like when i renewed my
driver's license i
just actually just sent sent them the
license in the mail uploaded a scan of
my picture and then i just renewed it
for me okay you can't do that in
australia yeah i mean
we've really been like the uk's gotten
really good at making things that it's
sufficient
and i guess i just took that for granted
right sure did god
sure yeah yeah yeah like everywhere's
like this like i'm i'm like
i'm like i i thank god that we're signed
with geeks plus and they handle our
attacks
yeah because like oh god i can only
imagine doing i've heard horror stories
i mean i did my attacks
before joining geek spots and it was the
[ __ ] worst
if you are a freelancer in japan good
luck i've heard i mean i mean
freelance tax forms in japan oh it is
doing tax in the uk is bad enough and
i'm just like if that was bad
how is it in [ __ ] japan oh it's god
awful i hate it i regret it
you know i thought it was bad in the uk
but then now i look back at how
doing taxes on the uk i'm like
everything could be done online yeah
everything can be done online at home
pretty good there's an app you know like
in japan you have to take a [ __ ] bag
full of receipts to like the town
and like yeah go through all of it and
like fill it in yourself oh my god it is
the worst
that's why that's why there's no
freelancers in japan because they're
like [ __ ] that i don't want to deal with
that [ __ ]
join the company that's so simple the
worst i will say though
it was pretty cool the first time i
discovered the hunger and it you know
it's cool for 10 seconds until it
becomes a burden yeah it's it's cool for
like the first week you live in here
when you're like oh i'm i'm
i'm oh i'm part of stamp now i'm part of
the culture here let me let me put my
signature look at my clan it's the
manitoba clan
because that's what it feels like right
when you're [ __ ] stamping your
second name down you're like making like
a really like traditional like kind of
swirly like
yeah yeah feudal japan style stamp it
looks dope
it looks dope i can i can see why they
haven't like gotten rid of it because it
feels like i feel cultured as i'm
stamping my [ __ ] name down
you know you know you know when you see
like an old in old films where you know
they're writing a letter and they're
[ __ ] stamped down yeah that's what it
feels like every time i
every time i snap down my hand but then
it gets to a point where you live here
for a year and you're just like
[ __ ] sake can we not just go back to
your signature
you know you stamp it and they're like
no it's not good enough you haven't
stamped it enough
what do you mean i can read it oh it's
slightly crooked can you feel the name
again please okay if it's slightly
crooked
if there's slightly not enough ink on it
they just won't accept it yeah also i
remember i filled out like this
three-page document
and i made one mistake and i uh did the
the line through it
and the guy at the the driving license
place like you gotta redoodle
yeah i'm like why it's like you've made
a mistake you gotta redo it i mean you
can't cross things out here
i'm like i'm like i crossed it out
though it's not a hundred percent
accuracy only in japan i'm like
what do you mean you can clearly there
is no any percent in japan only a
hundred percent rise yeah
you can clearly make out there is
absolutely no problem here
you know that i i don't mean the thing
that i crossed out and you know the
thing
what i meant to put yeah why are you
gonna make me fill out this three-page
document
again because i made one mistake it's
like it's it's like
everything is a [ __ ] like trapeze act
where you [ __ ] up you gotta redo
your whole life yeah just born do life
again reset life
jesus yeah only perfection here i'm
surprised that you know you need to
really fill out a document
like nope no license for you come back
next day can we do it again
basically if you want to live in japan i
hope you like filling out forms
because you are correctly yeah correctly
because you are no mistake
expect perfection in everything it's
like moving here is kind of like form
simulator 2021 honestly
papers please but every day
it's exhausting man yeah that's that's
kind of why like i'm dreading these next
few months when we move
studios and move houses i'm gonna be in
a foul mood
in like in like october when i have to
move i'm just gonna not want to talk to
anyone
[ __ ] you yeah yeah if we're complaining
now about this when we actually start
moving my god i'll probably
because it's because i know so much more
depressing because i know i'm gonna lose
at least a week
just from this alone so sorry if you
don't get any videos for late that month
my [ __ ] video schedule is like the
slowest it's ever been because of the
show because of this [ __ ] it's it
shouldn't be like that
it's ridiculous how did normal people
who work
nine to five oh sorry i mean sorry uh
nine to twelve
uh in japan how do they have time to do
this stuff i don't understand
because people don't stop working here
and stuff closes on weekends here so
what do they do i don't understand they
take pay leave
they take a week oh are you serious they
take a week off to move oh wait don't
they only have
by law a week of paid holiday anyway
20 whole days so you lose what like
five you lose a quarter of your paid
holiday if you want to move here in
japan
if you want to do that moving as a
luxury
if you want to do anything in japan you
got to take a day off to call them up
and do it yeah exactly that's ridiculous
you want to oh
you know you can't you know if you want
to change your phone provider you've got
to take a day off work how weird is that
it's weird the fact that you can't just
do it like during a lunch break it's
ridiculous
yeah it's tragic it really is tragic so
as someone who has moved before joey
what is the moving experience like here
in japan
hell you've already you've worked
here in japan right i've moved twice now
oh you've moved twice yeah so
so the place i'm about to move to will
be my fourth place
oh [ __ ] okay yeah yeah yeah well you've
moved twice but you've had four places
well yeah how does that work well i mean
i moved in here and then i moved to
separate times sorry sorry i was like
wait that number
those numbers don't add up two plus two
equals
well the first time i move when i moved
from australia to japan
it was a lot easier for me because i had
help i had help from my
like my auntie so she did all the
paperwork for me because oh yeah
epic i don't know i didn't [ __ ] know
how to do it but then she was like
alright well now you know how to do it
i'm like
what do i
yeah i hope you're paying attention i'm
like thanks for expert mode
it's not even like a would you like to
listen to that again option
i hope you're listening yeah so the
first time when i moved here was fine
but then this from the second time on
when i moved to
you know my own place yeah it was hell
and it's and it's still hell this is the
third time i'm doing it now and it's
it's
not easier at all like the only thing
that makes it easier now is that you
know exactly
the list of things you need to do yeah
but the list of
going but the process of going through
that the time is not anymore the time is
not any more efficient it is just as
time-consuming right no one wants to
improve their life because they're like
well i just i i do want them
that's what i'm saying right you know
i've got asbestos i've got mold but you
know
frankly putting up that paper that's
what i'm saying like it's not an
understatement to say
that or not an overreaction to say that
moving in japan is a luxury
yeah and it shouldn't be a luxury it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
that's what that's that's why they're
able to charge the same amount when you
have to renew your contract
which is why i don't know we were
explaining this but the reason we're all
moving
is because when your contract ends for
like your rental period
normally you think it can just easily
roll over and stuff that's in the uk
that's how it does in the uk that's
that's how it did in time
for me yeah that's how i did in most
countries nope you've got to go through
the same process again and pay the same
fees
you're gonna pay two months of rent for
free yeah no reason yeah
because they want it it's like because
you've got to go [ __ ] you [ __ ] giving
you two months of
money for free for what for this shitty
apartment [ __ ] off